plus de conseil municipal mais une
mairie toujours dirigé depuis
l'annulation de l'élection par le
conseil d'état en août la ville de
trappes est gérée par une délégation
spéciale autonome une délégation
spéciale est composée pour une commune
de moins de trente cinq mille habitants
de 3,3 membres une traditionnellement
parce que ça nous arrive assez souvent
de nommer des délégations spéciales nous
prenons un ancien élu ancien maire en
général accompagnés de fonctionnaires
souvent à la retraite et qui ont
l'habitude de travailler avec les
collectivités pour trappe la commission
est composée de michel pons ancien maire
de villennes-sur-seine christian nicolet
directeur de préfecture à la retraite et
gilles croissant premier vice président
du tribunal judiciaire de versailles
objectif de la délégation spéciale c'est
de faire fonctionner la mairie et les
services communaux pendant cette période
et bien il y à des mariages qui doivent
être prononcés il y a
tout un travail administratif qui doit
continuer on peut pas se permettre une
interruption notamment du service public
ce qui serait défavorable évidemment aux
administrés est la délégation est aussi
chargée de préparer les élections
municipales partielles les scrutins
auront lieu les dimanches 10 et 17
octobre prochains cinq candidats sont
pour le moment déclaré